patrick dils vie peut-être cette
dernière heure de prison cet homme
accusé d'un double meurtre d'enfants a
déjà obtenu la révision son procès il
aura lieu du 20 au 26 juin prochain mais
ses avocats ont déposé une demande de
mise en liberté qui sera examinée demain
à reims une attente vécu avec beaucoup
d'émotion par les parents du jeune homme
jean et jacqueline qu'edouard da costa
et christian hocquard néons sont allés
rencontrer le refuge de la famille dils
c'est leur jardin tous les jours jean et
jacqueline se change les idées en
regardant les plants de tomates et les
arbres fruitiers quelques minutes de
répit après 14 ans de combats passés à
défendre leur fils hier on apprenait
dans le jardin vont en oublie le
problème on s'occupe de notre jardin
qu'on louait les to et qu'après quand on
est fatigué de jardin où l'on vient se
reposer la leptine à nous donne un petit
réconfort
réconfort ô combien dérisoire pour des
parents qui crient à l'injustice
à trois semaines d'un nouveau procès la
remise en liberté de leur fils n'est pas
une priorité parce qu'on s'est enfin
passé énormément
après le procès de reims et sera
automatiquement remis en liberté j'ai
plongé
blanchi et a scellé la force et à après
procès d'arras pour patrick dils le
temps s'est arrêté en janvier 89 quand
une cour d'assises le condamne à la
prison à vie pour le meurtre de deux
enfants
depuis il ne cesse de clamer son
innocence changer d'heure pourquoi non
on l'a vu ce week end là et on a parlé
longuement de son prêt de ce qui va se
passer demain
il est très confiant et il est bien dans
sa tête et où il abordera sereinement et
l'attendu 14 heures trois semaines c'est
plus rien
finalement pour lui c'est un poids lourd
un cantique jours ou trois semaines ces
trois semaines mais il attendu 14 ans à
3 semaines les attentes
demain c'est par téléphone que jean et
jacqueline apprendront si leur fils est
remis en liberté avant son nouveau
procès